salut à tous les gamers ces working on
surtout aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle
vidéo pour mes cinquante mille abonnés
wen et de squeeze bonjour et en gros on
a fait une vidéo donc alors soyez pas
étonné non je n'ai pas un snack dans les
mains j'ai un striker c'est normal j'ai
décidé de jouer à autre chose ceci dit
je vais proposer quand même quelque
chose de différent pour ses cinquante
mille abonnés que tout le temps jouer
avec mon style alors puisque j'avais
envie de me détendre un peu avec ou deux
choses n'en profites tu as il joua au
fusil à pompe et il fait semblant que
c'est rien que pour vous ouais voilà
c'est ça en fait cette vidéo pour donc
vous tenir au courant un peu de
l'avancement du projet du deuxième
épisode de donjons dans la peau de voir
quelques risques il y aura certainement
et c'est sur un deuxième et qu'ils
paient pour ça et en fait donc combler
vos demandes et passionné a eu quelques
projets en devoir parler un petit peu
tout à fait il semble avoir votre avis
parce que on est un peu imbécile ou donc
on sait pas exactement quoi faire
donc voilà je te laisse un peu expliqué
tu me le projet va cela en fait donc
c'est ça mon avait en gros deux bronzes
idée donc on avait une première idée en
fait c'étaient deux optiques d'armé à
dark nevers pardon axa wafa never je
sais quoi
enfin bon bref l'eau et donc les
clubbers du zèle et qu'en fait on fasse
si vous voulez un truc qu'on s'incorpore
dans le jeu où par exemple moins 5 ans
porte dans le jeu offert un contrat au
sniper irl mais dans le jeu
ou alors on fait un cache cache dans le
jeu est vraiment un truc qu'on est assez
marrant voilà on fait plutôt comme la
des raids avec la dernière récolte la
dernière dernière
oui c'est à dire qu'on fait pas un truc
un peu un peu irréel un peu à la fin
sans grands effets spéciaux quoi voilà
en fait c'est les deux principaux
projets nous le truc de faire un truc y
est enfin incorporez danger ça fait
vraiment un support original est super
intéressant je trouve donc on n'entend
pas fléchir à saint ambroix vos avis
parce que bon c'est comme vos avis qui
sont les plus importants donc hésité
puis surtout tu si on fait le truc sur
son daara que finalement foulé voilà
c'est un peu moins tout aussi on avait
peut-être décidé donc de sortir pour
noël haimer et en fait on n'est pas sûr
d'y arriver si on fait sur fond vert
c'est pas du bien sûr qu'on n'y arrivera
pas
c 'est pas pratiquement cessé sur as400
pour swan sûrs en 20 jours c'est
impossible c'est juin aux puces fois
donc je l'achète le fonds vert tu en as
ton école toit de dépêcher à manon et
gérard sénac tu vois je peux pas
m'empêcher de m'interroger je vois ça en
bas à gauche là où tu n'en fais une
petite quad fidh comme ça tranquillement
les données à les voiliers j'arrive pas
assez impulsif je peux pas quand je vois
un sniper l'objet de ram ainsi qu'est ce
que vous nous voilà ça c'est sniper dans
la dorsale et ping de pied call of duty
2 quoi ça ça ah ouais quart et a
commencé un colloque de ouais en gros à
dire voilà donc soit donc se marquer à
un truc sur fond vert en soit vous
marquez a un truc comme la dernière fois
on reste un peu dans quasiment toutes en
tout cas nous on va s'y mettre direct là
après je pense qu'on va on va direct
parler du projet voilà il faut faire
plus fort est amusant et puis et puis
voilà donc n'oubliez pas de nous dire
vous ce qui vous intéresse surtout parce
que parce que c'est ça qui compte six
ouais si on se donne pour faire un truc
un peu comme la dernière fois et qu'au
final vous trouvez ça pourrit là ça nous
fera chier et si on fait un truc sur
fond d'alcool trouver sa place à mais ça
me ferait chier aussi voilà je le sais
bien vous allez quand même voilà le
principal et mais voilà on va essayer de
trouver on va essayer de monter ou
voilà et ben voilà on se prend une colle
à tort et le chant temps plein droit aux
tarifs
on va essayer de juste après cette
partie de retrouver justement quelqu'un
le scénario des x et donc voilà on va se
concentrer sur soi un peu de temps déjà
salut c'est moi à des grosses balles de
stryker qui me passionnait tu laisses tu
ça me stresse un peu à l'ego alors toi
marché dit et tu vas mourir mec je vais
vider la ville web pour revenir au
projet voilà c'est juste ça qu'on les
dirait on sait bien qu'on a déjà fait
une vidéo concernant ben pour dire à peu
près la même chose sauf que on n'avait
vraiment aucune desespringalle fr alors
que l'on vous propose entre deux trucs
mais ce sera la dernière je vous rassure
y aura pas de troisième vidéo aux
phrases en fait pour le projet qu'est ce
que vous voulez travailler tralala
d'avancé
la dernière fois il ya
la prochaine fois ce sera enfin puis ce
sera la vidéo ce sera la vidéo elle-même
voilà tout à fait ben voilà j'espère en
tout cas que cette vidéo vous plaira que
ça marchera autant que le premier
épisode wii puis voilà en tout cas on va
se donner un vase brisé ont gardé un bon
papa pourtant on va se faire suer et
tout ça c'est génial
ouais en attendant bon c'est vrai que on
a chacun nos projets se déploient sur
notre endroit ouais c'est sûr c'est sûr
mais chose et puis et puis bien jouer
pour tes 50 mille abonnés ici beaucoup
regardent donc la vidéo sur ma chaîne
jeu
vous proposera encore soit une des
vidéos j'existe encore en tout cas une
c'est sûr que je vais faire c'est là je
me taper un bon délire c'est faire là le
test de la démo des lapins crétins avec
mike keane est à arras avec des barres
ça va être quand même assez rigolo ça va
le changer un peu de tout ce que je fais
d'habitude françois mativet donc voilà
je vais vous proposer ce sera vraiment
sympa ah non mais tu peux tu peux ne
suis pas méchante bonne idée moi
j'adhère
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'un jour
un youtuber fasse une série mais j'ai
pas l'aqinac dollars sont je peux pas à
une série sur jardin just dance company
ça serait super league je sais juste et
plus sauvage voilà qui n'est que je le
ferais mais franchement j'ai enfin bref
bon voilà écoutez j'ai en plus on espère
sincèrement va juste pour en finir avec
ça que vous nous dire à peu près tout à
faire ce que vous préférez
retrouvez façon voilà on va essayer de
sortir s'imposerait mais si c'est un
truc sur fond vert
sachez que ça sortira pas c'est clair
ces impôts ce sera pour 2012
ouais merde merde je fais du 14/01 mais
je n'arrive pas à jouer en live c'est
injuste 29 ans aux strikers attend
d'ailleurs franchement j'ai jamais lavés
[ __ ] mais je fais du 15 au 22 est une
[ __ ] triet quoi sert la veille c'est
bien que le toit assez fier de prendre
pour un con qui franchement c'est un
instinct c'est une semaine et chic
d'ailleurs c'est l'hiver est-ce que vous
ça vous fait chier d'être enrhumé comme
un gros alors moi je peux dire que j'ai
chauffé revue en plus ce qui m'énerve
c'est que les rhumes d'où ça vient je
vais vous donner ma théorie des ruches
amiens saint françois donc tu allais
quelqu'un qui font les gros kaki pour
les mecs qui arrivent un petit chien je
suis c'est tout mais au final il chope à
rubin voilà résultat à celui t'as un
kéké dans ta classe il te file son rhume
et résultat tu te retrouves enrhumé
alors tu aimes pas fait le kéké tu
t'ouvres grave c'est ça cesse et ça
c'est le partage de pin de bactéries
derrière ta voix fait à hawaï partir en
stage
c'est vrai mais franchement je trouve ça
absolument dégueulasse donc à tous les
kékés qui regarde cette vidéo s'il vous
plaît arrêtez arrêtez à chaque hiver de
venir en tenue et mettez le tout
interprété des [ __ ] de suite' ou des
pulls vraiment et voilà elle va et qui
c'est le seul qui meurent parce [ __ ]
bombardements et ben c'est limite au
malthusianisme moi je m'approche pic le
drone dassault sas avait été pillé mais
petit à petit j'ai fait le bon drôle
dassault dassault c'est énorme ce que
vous allez voir je sais pas si vous avez
déjà eu ce truc mais ses jeunes ouailles
moi je veux une côte fidh avec ce truc
pour lancer des missiles au pays tirée à
ses toiles arrière je suis derrière toi
iqu et vous allez voir et franchement ça
j'y jette un éclairage fait on éclaire à
aller à gauche il est là bas oha les
paraboles impossible au [ __ ] j'ai été
par michael o my world et my god oh
j'aime ou rien pourquoi je suis très
fier de mon dos à grenade d'accord allez
venez mouvement l'atripla les allées il
meurt pas tu veux pas mourir
allez ça ce sont les aléas de la vie les
allées avec mark et moi ce qui m'énerve
c'est les petits boulet qui prennent
leur [ __ ] de drones de merde la fin du
lock out pendant la partie il survole la
map et hôpitaux par a listé a dit
standard dans sa valise tu sais pas
comment ça peut pas ce truc en plus au
sort strictement à rien sauf si tu veux
enfin sauf si tu as encore mais ça s'est
mal passé
c'est abominable ces machins franchement
c'est vrai que je vais parler un autre
truc là j'ai vu une vidéo
des diabétiques nabeul qui avait passé
un petit coup de vieux sur sur w3
vraiment ce qu'il a dit je trouve qu'il
a raison et surtout à propos du district
soutien où il ya un bombardement quoi
rien franchement mais ça c'est ça en
fait c'est juste pour donner une chance
aux mecs un peu pourri tout c'est
d'avoir un hacker strict du tour
ouais mais franchement ça n'a rien à
voir c'est une classe soutien en quoi
c'est un soutien d'arracher la moitié de
la carpe
cela commençait à ses successeurs c'est
lui là mais bon voilà quoi
enfin bref on arrive à la fin de cette
petite vidéo on vous invite donc à bien
participé à bien que les automoteurs
bien partager vos vidéos
alors moi j'invite les kékés à se
couvrir dans cette marge
oui je comprends chaque année je me fais
le baiser aussi vous vous retrouvez dans
la description tous les liens donc la
chesnaie squeeze aurait également une
annotation durant toute la vidéo pour la
chesnaie squeeze je vous invite à aller
voir ce qu'il fait c'est un mec qui lui
manque une case mais qui fait des
critiques
bah pareil pareil pour ceux qui
regardent la vidéo sur ma chaîne a moins
il y aura une rotation vers la chine
d'avoir take bon je pense que vous
connaissez
on va quand même là m qu'est donc voilà
c'est la fin de ces vidéos j'espère que
vous avez apprécié oubliez pas d'essayer
commentaires et on se retrouve très
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo c'était
warteck et squeeze
[Musique]